i
[Música]
ah
un plan para masificar la vacunación
contra el kobe 19 comenzó hace un mes en
venezuela hay decenas de centros en todo
el país pero en general el proceso se ha
desarrollado de forma lenta y es
ordenada las largas filas son una
constante el gobierno asigna el turno
para vacunarse a través de un mensaje de
texto pero igual son muchos los
ciudadanos que sin ser convocados se
acercan a un centro de vacunación
confiando que la suerte estará de su
lado y podrán recibir la vacuna no hay
cifras oficiales de cuántas personas
recibieron la primera o las dos dosis
tampoco hay claridad sobre el número de
vacunas que han llegado al país sin
embargo el ministro de salud dijo a
principios de este mes que venezuela ya
contaba con suficientes vacunas para
inmunizar a casi tres millones de
personas de una población de casi 30 el
presidente nicolás maduro ha dicho que
espera a inocular al 70% de la población
para diciembre la ong médicos unidos ha
tildado el plan de vacunación como una
anarquía y ha criticado la decisión
oficial de aplicar la candidata a vacuna
la cubana abdalá que aún no ha sido
autorizada por la organización mundial
de la
continúa en honduras la quinta jornada
de vacunación anti kobe priorizando a
personas de entre 50 a 60 años de edad
así como personal sanitario que aún
faltaba por vacunarse trabajadores en el
sector funerario sector turismo y
educativo
honduras con una población de un poco
más de 9.5 millones de habitantes apenas
han ingresado a este país un poco más de
un millones de vacunas provenientes
mayormente de donativos y algunas
compras del gobierno hace un par de días
ingresó un lote de 1.5 millones de
vacunas modernas luego de un donativo
del gobierno de los estados unidos a
través del mecanismo kóvacs
simultáneamente entraban al país unas
150 mil vacunas extras técnicas donadas
por el gobierno de mexico y el
presidente hernández anunció que las
próximas horas llegará a un lote de
vacunas pzifer aproximadamente unas
60.000 con esto el gobierno pretende
vacunar un millones de personas
antes de que finalice el mes de julio
sin embargo otros 6 millones elegibles
continúan en lista de espera
casi el 30% de su población vacunada a
marruecos es la excepción en áfrica en
este país se ha inoculado más del 90%
del total de dosis recibidas en el
continente y es que la escasez de
vacunas y el acaparamiento por parte de
los países ricos está teniendo
consecuencias devastadoras para áfrica
donde aparte de no estar recibiendo las
dosis que se requieren la mayoría de
sistemas sanitarios están muy
debilitados y las cifras de contagios y
de muertes siguen incrementando en todo
el continente además a la nueva variante
de alta se ha detectado al menos en 14
países y la onza ha advertido de que
áfrica se enfrenta a su mayor oleada de
kobe 19 hasta la fecha y el total de
población vacunada no llega ni tan solo
al 3% y por otra parte epidemiólogos y
expertos advierten de que la magnitud de
la tragedia podría ser aún mayor en el
continente en caso de que el virus mute
se convierta en una enfermedad más grave
o que se haga inmune al efecto de las
vacunas disponibles
[Música]